on a d'abord entendu parler du
microbiote chez l'humain en cet ensemble
de bactéries et de champignons qui
colonise entre autres nous intestins et
depuis d'autres microbiote sont scrutées
de près comme celui du fromage celui des
arbres en agriculture on se soucie de
plus en plus de l'ensemble des
micro-organismes qu'on retrouve dans le
sol et notamment du microbiote des blés
[Musique]
des gestes qui ont de l'histoire on
fabriquera du pain depuis 12 milles 1
[Musique]
pourtant malgré des décennies de
recherche
le père renferme encore beaucoup de
mystères
qu'est ce qui donne la structure et la
qualité de nos pattes
comment développer tous les bon goût du
bon pain
[Musique]
pour trouver ces réponses certains
revisite les nombreuses variétés
qu'offre le blé mais d'autres vont
encore plus loin et fouillent désormais
les micro-organismes qui colonisent le
blé sont microbiote le pain c'est juste
la suite de ce qui s'est passé dans le
sol c'est comment la plante s'est
exprimé toutes les qualités du sol
[Musique]
nous sommes dans l'une des plus
importantes fabriques de farine
artisanale en amérique du nord à saint
jean sur richelieu près de montréal
dans ce nouveau complexe
le mini robert beauchemin a fait
construire une boulangerie expérimental
c'est ici que ce designer de farine gut
s'est peint et qu'il réfléchit notre
star d'or pour ses mechelen 9 cm et l'on
n'était du senior de deux volumes et la
mishna pas étalé comme une pizza donc le
volume ses prix en altitude plutôt que
que sept ans les mules y ont toujours
recherché des farines qui contiennent
beaucoup de gluten le gluten est la
protéine essentielle en boulangerie
[Musique]
pour obtenir des blés avec un maximum de
gluten
on a toujours fertiliser les champs avec
des doses massives d'azoté mais robert
beauchemin s'interroge sur ce dogme
ça fait 35 ans qu'ils achètent ces blés
au québec
à force de comparer leurs performances
il a remarqué un détail important humble
et de même variété fertiliser avec les
mêmes quantités d'azoté donne des
farineau qualité boulangère variable
quand il pousse dans des terroirs
différents
ce qu'on s'est rendu compte que la
qualité de ces protéines là il n'était
pas là on a des blés qui sortait à 14,14
huit autres protéines qui était pas plus
performants au point de vue boulanger
qu'un humble et à 12 me venant d'un
autre environnement
ces différences se font aussi sentir
quand ils comparent d'esbly provenant de
l'agriculture intensive avec des blés
issus de l'agriculture biologique
on voyait déjà dans les sols bio des
qualités de protéines à taux de
protéines égale des comportements
boulanger supérieur parfois à ce qu'ils
étaient dans le conventionnel
pourquoi une telle différence y
aurait-il dans le terroir peu
d'ingrédients négliger un ingrédient qui
influencent la qualité des protéines du
blé pour mieux comprendre le muni va se
tourner vers la science et vers cet
homme etienne hier jour
à l'institut armand-frappier à laval ce
microbiologiste fait pousser des blés
toutes sortes de blé mais ce qui
intéresse le chercheur
ce n'est pas tant ceux qui sortent de
terre mais plutôt ce qui se cache dans
le sol et plus précisément ceux qui vit
ici à la surface de ses racines loger du
microbiote sont mes doigts un peu
partout il y en a plein sur les racines
et à des milliards des milliards de
bactéries sur chaque centimètre carré de
c'est une densité incroyable c'est un
des écosystèmes de prudence en termes de
micro-organismes les bactéries et les
champignons qui colonise ses racines ont
tout autant besoin du blé pour survivre
que le blé a besoin d'eux une plante
isolé stérile registre est stérile dans
le sens des repas de microbes dessus ça
n'existe pas dans la nature
c'est pas juste une plante pas juste là
l'autre comme on dit c'est l'oqlf tous
les micro organismes associés à cette
plante
en fouillant sur ses racines le
chercheur a découvert qu'elle était
colonisé par des champignons et des
bactéries impliqué dans le cycle de la
zot lé azote est essentiel au blé mais
pour l'extraire de la matière organique
la plante doit conclure un pacte avec
les microorganismes du sol le blé va
émettre à la surface de ses racines des
sucres afin de recruter des bactéries
capables de digérer la zot du sol ces
micro organismes vont coloniser le
pourtour de ses racines
ils vont se nourrir des sucres et en
retour ils vont fournir ou bhl est tous
là zot nécessaire pour fabriquer ces
protéines dont le gluten mais le
chercheur veut faire un pas de plus il
veut identifier les lignes et de
bactéries qui donne de meilleurs farine
boulangère pour y parvenir il va
déployer les grands moyens
[Musique]
l'équipe de l'institut armand-frappier
va parcourir les champs de blé du québec
et recueillir et dizaines d'échantillons
de sol en laboratoire son équipe va
ensuite débusquer chacune des grandes
familles de micro-organismes qui
peuplent ses échantillons
[Musique]
pendant ce temps robert beauchemin s'est
elle lui aussi à la taz il teste la
performance des blés dessus de chacun de
ses champs ensemble ces érudits this les
premiers liens entre ceux qui vit dans
le sol et les performances boulangère
des blés la cartographie des
micro-organismes reste à compléter mais
déjà une tendance se dessine et elles
semblent confirmer les observations du
meunier
les blés qui donne les meilleures
performances boulangère ont tous poussé
dans des sols dont l'activité biologique
est élevé plus important encore c'est ça
le renfermé une très grande diversité de
micro-organismes plussieurs micro micro
hommes différents dans un sol plus une
possibilité d'avoir les bons microbes
justement qui vont faire en sorte que la
nutrition d'ubs livre est optimale pour
avoir une une qualité boulangère aussi
optimale
les recherches ont aussi permis
d'identifier des groupes clés de
micro-organismes qui favorise une
meilleure absorption de la zot par la
plante
cela se traduirait par une qualité
supérieure de protéines ce qui en bout
de piste donnerait à la pâte une bien
meilleure ossature la qualité la
protéine va faire en sorte que le frais
marges vont obtenir assez longtemps la
fermentation pour que opus épanouir les
saveurs à leur maximum
si la protéine est pas bien structuré
on va développer et ça ça vaut et
transit de fonds propres de la vie du
sol s'exprimerait donc jusque dans le
four à pain s'est pas encore très clair
on tombe dans du nouveau là dedans mais
on voit qu'une différence entre d'un
extrême les sols cultivés intensivement
les sols en conventionnel des sols en
agriculture raisonnée et dans le bios
chacun un step différents plateaux
différents de performance
[Musique]
étienne hier jo n'est pas surpris de ces
résultats
il constate que là où l'agriculture
utilise des fortes doses d'engrais de
synthèse et de pesticides
les sols sont plus pauvres en
microorganismes
à l'opposé la rotation des cultures où
le recours aux engrais vert favorise une
plus grande vis dans le sol on pourrait
voir ça comme un terrain un buffet petit
lapin peut choisir à les choisir ses
partenaires préférés puis ceux qui vont
être les plus bénéfiques pour sa
croissance
à terme le chercheur croit que ces
nouvelles connaissances serviront à
mieux gérer les quantités d'azoté
épandues houchin surtout que ces engrais
sont responsables d'une partie de la
pollution des cours d'eau
parfois ce n'est pas de plus dans grey
dont le blé a besoin mais bien des
microbes qui assimile ce qui est déjà
dans le sol pourrait certainement vous
passez qu'on pourra voir des bonnes
qualité boulangère juste un manipulant
ou un gérant de façon optimale notre
micro bio du sol puis henri faisant neuf
utilisations d'azoté
si on met plein d'azad dans un sol qui
ont nécessairement la bonne diversité
microbienne on en raffole
l'effet escompté sur la qualité
boulangère on vient juste de soulever un
petit peu le tpiy et c'est incroyable
comment ça bouge entoure c'est comme
sylvain caillou le pour le munier le
microbiote du blé encore beaucoup de
secrets à livrer et de saveurs à fournir
à ces farines mais ces premières
connaissances lui rappelle l'importance
de prendre soin du sol avant de penser à
nourrir une plante avec des engrais de
synthèse la nature et vie de complexité
de ramener sa des éléments trop simple
on n'aide pas la nature donc de
respecter et même d' amplifier cette
complexité le amène un plus grand
équilibre dans la diversité biologique
qui dans le sol
[Musique]
où
c'est pour certains le pain symbolise
l'alliance ultime entre l'homme et la
terre c'est mon prennent désormais tout
leur sens quand on connaît mieux le
microbiote du blé
[Musique]
oh